talking about Donald Trump again because
we have to he's the elephant in the room
and so hopefully this will be the last
time I have to talk about him but Donald
Trump i think is headed for a 1984 style
butt whippin if you were alive then you
may remember Walter Mondale getting
thrashed electoral II if the pull up the
real clear average oppose for me you can
see that right now on the national level
and this isn't a two-way race the
numbers are pretty much give or take a
few percentage points in the same area
with the four-person race with jill
stein and with gary johnson but in the
to pull up to two candidate race Hillary
Clinton is destroying Donald Trump by
seven points the average oppose the
highest spread there is the 12 points by
the month Monmouth poll 11 points CBS
this is uh it Pat this is shaping up to
be a thorough but whipping I mean this
is radio so I can't say what i want to
say but i really believe and i don't
want people to take for granted I think
Donald Trump is facing the type of
butt-whipping that he's never
experienced in his life at least not
he's never as conceded that he ever lost
anything but this is shaping up to be
pretty bad he's even he's down so much
that the Clinton campaign has started
investing dollars in red states they're
running ads in Texas in Arizona like
there's no reason that Donald Trump
should have to spend money in those two
states but because he's down so poorly
so badly um they're running they're
running ads there what do you think and
of course on all these poles there's
some margin of error right usually it's
about three and a half percent but that
could mean that he's doing actually even
worse yet Hillary's up an extra three
and a half percent on top of the polls
that are there and yeah they're playing
ads in Arizona they're trying to push
for that state they're trying to push
for Georgia and South Carolina this is
going to be like nothing that I've seen
before yeah yeah if you go to the the
next image there's a real clear average
electoral map that gives you an idea of
what this could look like it's so far
the 256 for Hillary Clinton those are
solidly for Hillary Clinton there's a
40 that are most likely for Clinton
Hillary Clinton and 101 that lean
towards Hillary Clinton where there's a
hundred and twelve that are up for grabs
112 electoral votes that are up for
grabs if this goes down the way people
are expecting this could turn out very
poorly for Donald Trump here's the thing
this is the important thing I don't
think anyone should mistake this to be a
mandate or Hillary Clinton this is a
mandate this is a repudiation of Donald
Trump this is America saying we do not
want Donald Trump we would tolerate
Hillary Clinton more than we would
accept ever except Donald Trump and I
want people to be mindful of that
because the fair first thing you're
going to hear from Hillary Clinton is
that the American people have spoken and
we have a mandate no you don't have a
mandate Hillary you just have an
American electorate body politic that
rejects Donald Trump and would rather
deal with an establishment character
like yourself well it's a very important
distinction and you'd hope at least that
the Republicans in Congress would put
forward the Supreme Court nominees that
she were to a point yeah and they've
already said they've already said that
they're going to reject I think it was
what's the last guy who McCain they
already said they're going to reject any
nominee or they're not going you know
they already said they're going to be
intransigent right which is no big big
surprise the question is how long will
they block the government how long would
they block the powers the levers of
power to make sure the America actually
gets to operate the way it's designed
operate we'll see but part of me wants
we have to be clear and we have to be
sober with Hillary Clinton because this
is not a mandate and we hope that some
of the good things particularly her tax
policy it's not the best tax policy but
it's by far much better than Donald
Trump's I would hope that she can get
things like that passed but we really
have to keep a watchful eye because we
don't want her to run across the nation
with a lot of policies that she feels
she's in power to give because she has a
mandate and i hope this pushes her into
a position where she has to reckon
is the importance of her base I don't
think that's the case I don't think
that's how is actually gonna play out
but I really think it's important that
even though Donald Trump is going to get
his butt with the November it's
important that people realize this is
not so much we love Hillary Clinton as
much as it is we absolutely
unequivocally reject Donald Trump I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David